- Everyone loves sauce,
(curious mellow funky music)
but in Korea, there is one sauce
that goes on everything: gochujang.
It's tangy, it's sweet, it's spicy.
And in Korea, no one makes it better
than the people in this small town.
Welcome to Sunchang Village.
(moves into funky spacey music)
(moves into curious playful music)
(speaking in foreign language)
Meet Seo Youngsoon.
She's been making gochujang for 40 years.
(speaking in foreign language)
Gochujang gets its taste from
fermented soy bean bricks.
Sunchang Village has a
naturally humid climate
that is perfect for fermenting the beans.
(rattling)
(speaking in foreign language)
(rustling)
(rattling)
But Seo Youngsoon likes to let
hers ferment a little bit longer.
(speaking in foreign language)
(moves into pleasant
playful orchestral music)
Seo Youngsoon doesn't want
her town's famous sauce
to be forgotten, so she
offers workshops to visitors
in the hopes they will learn
how to make her special sauce
and continue the gochujang tradition.
(murmuring)
(speaking in foreign language)
(squishing)
(sonic wave)